what I want to talk about is work I've
done in uh yeah in fairing nature in
physics biology and using machine
learning and to keep things interesting
uh I'm trying to phrase the conversation
as if it's a match between humans and
nature where humans score points when
they infer something new about nature
and nature scores points when it's
making it harder for us and trying to to
keep us at Bay uh so yeah so you might
think that since everybody here so I'm
talking to people so might might think
that uh it be would be team human but
even in ancient Greece there were the
Skeptics that maintain that nature
cannot be uh known so maybe even in the
audien there like this like different
teams uh excellent so we start with this
fundamental question what are the
fundamental laws the fundamental actions
of the
universe and the thing is that we don't
know we don't know and uh this is
depressing because we start being very
ambitious and trying to uh kick off the
project of infering nature off the
ground uh but there is no ground there
is no Bedrock upon which to build
systematically and trying to to infer
the rest of nature this is in Star
contrast with mathematics uh where uh we
have axioms that we postulate and then
we take for granted as bedrock and we
start inferring uh Alex was very nicely
explaining how there are some
prerequisites for picking those axim uh
but then then we use them as given
whereas we don't have that in science
there's no Bedrock it's more like a
swamp that you're trying to butr
yourself out of uh so why do I say that
we don't have the fundamental axium of
the
universe uh it's because experiments
suggest that there are four forces that
describe interaction of matter with
other matter electromagnetism the strong
nuclear force the weak nuclear force and
gravity and and the first three have
been unified in a common framework that
we call the standard model of particle
physics but the fourth one hasn't uh
been incorporated into a common framewor
this is why we don't have the aims
because we cannot in a unified framework
describe
everything uh and the reason for that is
ultimately how they deal with
information the first three forces
explicitly preserve information whereas
the fourth Force at least on phe value
seems to destroy it and since you can't
have both simultaneously it's very hard
to put them
together uh and
uh it's very hard to put them together
but it's not like Str theorists have
given up and and they have been trying
to resolve this information Paradox
first introduced by Hawking who
incidentally was previous in previous
PhD committee
um and what they have figured out lately
as of five years ago uh is that
information seems to be lost in our
universe because of the presence of baby
universes that constantly split off of
our universe and then Marge back on it
it and if you take into account those
effects of universes splitting off of
ours and merging to this one you can
actually reproduce this effect that
information seems to be lost because you
only have access to one Universe uh and
there was a paper s little paper about
Maxfield and Maro in 2020 and also our
paper
from uh from uh last year that yeah
reproduces this effect uh so in our
paper we used topological quantum
gravity so so we had the regular gravity
you have in our universe and we unified
it and reproduced resolved uh hogin
Paradox not with these three forces that
I'm showing there but with another uh
Force which was described by topological
Quantum field Theory so we did uh so in
in this model which is a rigorous and
analytically exactly computable model
you had a common framew which said
gravity and non-gravitational forces and
you were resolving the information
Paradox but so there is there is a lot
of progress uh
I'm trying to say but still we UniFi
gravity with a completely random other
force not with these three so still we
don't have the fundamental
aims and you might say that oh that's uh
that's bad uh but but now I'm doing
competition biology so we don't need to
we don't need gravity for that and if
I'm saying that we understand the first
three forces uh nearly perfectly then
why not make a a simulation uh oh by the
way yeah so this lack of LW of physics
uh is how nature keeps us at Bay poses a
first challenge nobody gives us the
accents of of the
universe but like I was saying we don't
need gravity so how about doing the
following thing like discretizing space
and putting the standard model of
particle physics on that discretized
space and then try to perfectly simulate
the cell uh that would be super cool
because then we will be able to find
Initial particle configuration in the
cell then simulate a drug coming in and
seeing exactly what effect would have so
we would be able to abinal calculate
drugs and stuff so can we perfectly
simulate a cell and of course there's
nothing particular about a cell can we
simulate the universe of or parts of it
perfectly and and unfortunately there's
a theorem that says that you cannot do
that uh it's the nilson inia theorem and
more precisely it says that you cannot
simulate the standard Port the standard
model of particle physics
uh in on a discretized
space um and since the standard mod of
particle physics is our universe that
means that you cannot simulate the
universe uh the proof of that relies in
two ideas the idea is the first idea is
that the standard model has chyal
particles which means that when a
particle like rotates spins like this it
can move in only one of two directions
either this way or or the opposite way
and you call this right-handed and this
left-handed
yeah so those are the only two
possibilities it allows and in fact it's
interesting that it picks prefers the
right hand the left-handed uh particles
but those are the only two possibilities
and the second idea is something that we
learn in undergrad in physics that when
you have discretized space momentum is
periodic uh that means that uh identical
like that values of the momentum
periodically are completely equivalent
using those two ideas you can prove that
the St particle physics cannot exist in
distalized space because if you have a
particle a rightand particle like that
then this positive momentum since we're
in discretized space would be completely
equivalent to being negative but that
means that this particle would be both
left-handed and right-handed but the
modal part model that treats those
particles
differently which is an absurd and by
absur we prove that uh this cannot be
happening so so so there's another way
to look at this uh so this answers the
question of whether we live in The
Matrix as Professor David Kong from
Trinity College uh likes to phrase it if
we cannot simulate the universe then
this indeed could not be a simulation uh
we cannot be living in The Matrix
because then CERN wouldn't be giving uh
the data results that is giving
us uh yeah however it's nice to say that
uh it's comforting that
um that uh what I'm experiencing is not
uh a simulation but like from a
scientific point of view it's depressing
it's another point for nature because we
cannot have perfect simulations of of
the fundamental laws as we understand
them um oops oops oh yeah so we don't
know the aims of the universe even when
we do know them we cannot perfectly
simulate them uh what's left then uh
well clearly what's left is to do
experiments but they come with their own
issues uh and in particular all of uh
analyzing data because the moment you
get your data you have to analyze them
and interpret them and then you run into
the generalizability problem uh which of
course um it's like a cylinder if you
look at from the top it manifests in
different ways depending on your
perspective and yeah even even in
philosophy people have looked into to
that right even in ancient Greece sexus
empirical David Hume that we heard about
uh also the rule following I like to
think of as this generalizability
problem um and yeah so it consists of
the fly thought experiment if you like
have an apple and you drop it you uh you
see it fall to the ground and if you
reput that 100 times keeps happening but
are you allowed the 100 first time uh to
conclude um to conclude that it surely
will be like the previous ones that it
will fall to the ground
in other words generalizability is about
arguing from observed cases based on
observed cases about unseen
cases and in machine learning we're
interested in those cases when the
Unseen cases we know a priority that
they're bound to different a
bit um and yeah so that's why you call
it out of distribution prediction or as
of late in the context of uh
foundational models we refer to it as
zero shot
learning uh um yeah so and and in that
context so so in general if we know if
we allow the unn cases to be arbitrarily
different than the sin cases then
clearly uh we cannot possibly conclude
something about them we can conclude
something about what you haven't
observed and this is the this goes by
the name essentially of the no freelance
theorem uh what it says more uh more
specifically is that an algorithm can
only be better at finding a data
generating distribution only at the
expense of being worse at finding
another one at in fairing another one so
alternative algorithm a will on average
have the same performance than any other
algorithm when you average across all
problems um yeah so this is a final uh
uh another point for for nature which is
leading by now uh by three points
uh so how are we pushing back against
this generalizability problem what can
we do about this this issue well what we
can do about it is what comes as a
rescue is using constraints from prior
knowledge that's the way to get off so
what general what the nor freelance
theorem introduces is this trade-off
between uh bias and variance the way to
get rid of it is to introduce prior
knowledge constraints and the way to do
that is to start Gathering a lot of data
and start noticing patterns for instance
you can impose the pattern that your
model has to have sparsity and therefore
data sets that could not be produced by
sparse models would be rejected and that
would allow your algorithm a to over to
overperform other algorithms in the
relevant cases that haven't been
excluded but of course in biology we're
trying to push further ahead from that
and that's what the human cell Atlas
tries to do instead of just using
sparcity we're in using compiling very
comprehensive data sets of both
observational and
Interventional uh data across many
organs diseases donors uh both uh both
for single cell and also spatially I'm
not sure if this has a pointer but like
here you can see that uh now we know
that like what genes are expressed in
this point versus what other genes are
expressed in this other point of this
section of the
tissue uh I should also say that the
human cell Atlas is uh CED by
uh by Professor Sarah tman and aiv RV
and it's this effort of trying to map
all the different cell types that exists
that exist in in the human body because
although all the cells in my body have
the same exactly genome they make
different choices and the cell in my eye
decides to be an eye cell and the cell
on my skin a skin cell uh so they decide
to focus on different parts of the
genome and undergo what we refer to as
differentiation and in order to to
understand better human health and
disease we're trying to map out all the
different possibilities that cells have
to to opt
for um yeah so that's how we push back
we start Gathering now biological prior
knowledge and build models based on
that and that's how we start pushing
back against nature by compiling though
this is this is a very uh big Consortium
and a huge effort in in single cell
biology
uh and furthermore uh in in my work in
progress in the RO flashy lab uh we're
building this thisp model which is uh
which stands for distant tangle of varat
to predict
counterfactuals and and it lies at the
intersection between distant tangle
learning fairness and and um and
causality and our idea is that during
the training process we we augment the
data by by matching that app with one
another to produce contrafactual Pairs
and then during the training process we
constantly uh do the three steps of
abduction action and prediction and and
penalize the training process so we
during the training process we're trying
to predict contactors and make a model
that predicts them
better uh yeah in order to to have a
better performance for out of
distribution
prediction um another thing what comes
to the rescue about not knowing uh the
fundamental axum of the universe is
another idea from theoretical physics
which is the renormalization
group and which essentially says that
phenomena at different length scales are
siloed from one another they
don't uh they don't yeah so phenomena at
the subatomic level are not relevant for
phenomena at much larger length scales
yeah more precisely what it says is that
a theor
uh that tries to explain a phenomenon at
a specific length scale should
be should be phrased with degrees of
freedom uh that are in the same length
scale and in that way that theory will
manage we will manage to have it be um
uh elegant and have it be like need a
finite number of measurements in order
to be
predicted um yeah so imagine like in the
context of a disease spreading
uh clearly the relevant degrees of
freedom to capture would be the bacteria
and that were like discovered by Robert
Co and then we would be able to build a
nice theory of how disase spreads
clearly we could also try to do it with
subatomic degrees of freedom but with a
huge monster that uh could do it but it
wouldn't be any better in doing so uh
than if we had used the rise degrees of
freedom because ultimately our immense
success in designing drugs and
understanding biology tells us that the
tiny details in which gravity is
quantized in this way or in another
slightly different way couldn't possibly
matter that's what this uh theorem the
normalization group tells us uh at The
Other Extreme you could try think of
trying to explain how disase spreads by
using not allowing yourself to use the
notion of bacteria and build a theory
solely at the people's level
uh and you don't have to think uh to
imagine that because in medieval Europe
that's exactly what people were doing
they were using this now debunked uh
theory about how diseases spread the
miasma theory invented by ancient Greek
Physicians miasma in Greek means a
pollutant they were thinking of it as a
as a cloud that settles upon the town
and causes people to suffer and then
that cloud arbitrarily decides to move
to the next town over um and yeah they
had built this Theory which was you
could due to weird confounders you could
make it be predictive uh they put the PO
they surrounded the PO with fire and
that protected him but it was clear
because it was keeping the sick people
out and not any weird clouds
um um yeah so so you could also build a
theory like that but you would have to
constantly keep modifying it based on
weird uh confounders and weird patterns
that arise because you haven't captured
the real
things uh and that is another thing that
rescues us uh to do biology I don't need
to simulate the standard model of
particle physics uh like you have
suspected um and indeed so in biology
most of the time we end up
using uh most of our problems are
combinatorial they have to do about
molecules and concentrations of the
molecules in in Solutions but we don't
need to simulate uh Atomic Dynamics
sometimes molecular but uh most of the
time it's combinatorial problems and for
those you can reliably use
simulations for instance in in this
other work on the
package empty drops we we had the
there's the following very important
problem in computational
biology so right now in biology uh we
can figure out like I was telling you
like different cells opt for different
choices combinations of genes to
express so so it's important to like be
able to sequence and figure out what
genes each cell expresses and in order
to do that you have to capture the cell
and count all the molecules in it but
some sometimes you're trying to capture
it and and you miss and you capture next
to it a solution uh like yeah water with
some RNA and DNA molecules in that
random uh water that you because those
molecules leaked from cells or nuclei
into the water so sometimes you capture
the cell and sometimes you you don't but
you think you have because it's you
still capture RNA and that risks
confounding Downstream analysis because
sometimes you have noise and you can
mistake it be a real cell and then start
imagining that you have a new cell type
so it's a huge problem in computational
biology and and there are some methods
to to deal with that uh for instance
there is this famous algorithm that
people use in computation biology it's
called cell Ranger and it says that oh
come on if you capture
noise uh it must be so much less than a
real cell that has a lot of RNA and DNA
in it so I'm just going to say that all
the
uh observations that have a lot of RNA
and DNA are real cells and all the other
ones are just noise but of course if the
signal to noise ratio starts being bad
you cannot make that distinction and and
yeah so what if you have a cell that has
as much RNA as the noise then clearly
you're either going to have too many
false positives or false negatives you
need a better method to do it and uh our
idea was to to go in the observations
that have uh very few RNA and DNA
molecules so if it has 10 RNA molecules
that must be noise there's no cell with
just 10 RNA molecules so so great so
those are surely noise and then if you
put all of these together you can create
a profile of the
noise and then you can go in the cases
where indeed are ambiguous and so here
it's how many the molecules you have and
here how many AR molecules you have so
in these are biggest ones that are in
the middle and you don't know like which
they are since you have profiled the
noise you can do a statistical
hypothesis test whether the observation
is statistically close to the
distribution you created for the noise
and if they deviate you think of them as
cells that that was our idea which
doesn't make uh pity assumptions about
the expected
cells and indeed in a simulation we show
that we're doing a lot better than uh
cell Ranger because so what we did in
this simulation is we took a data set
that processed by cell Ranger cell
Ranger thinks that the red ones are
cells and the black ones are uh not cell
and we took a thousand observations of
the ones it thinks are cells and we
downsampled the number of counts in each
one to simulate a small cell which
should be realistic because it's like
a a reduction absum again right so I'm
saying that oh okay competitor I agree
with you and you're right then let's
down sample that
then then you can see here that cell
Ranger does miss the green population of
small cells whereas we find it because
those that small cell still has uh is
statistically different than the
noise um
yeah
so um yeah excellent and in other in
other uh projects in the T tman lab were
focusing on the following very important
Pro problem
uh which is uh so in multicellular
organisms in order to to function and
since by definition they have many cells
those many different cells need to
coordinate their activities uh for
instance if my eyes see see something
there of my body needs to potentially go
in a fight or flight mode and so they
need to communicate this signal that my
eyes got uh so so there's this need of
cellular communication and how they
communicate at least one of the ways
they can communicate is by the sending
cell excreting a a molecule that we call
the the LI that Li moving on until it
reaches the receiving cell that has
another molecule on its surface that we
call the receptor and it activates the
receptor and causes something inside the
receiving
cell however some receptors are uh some
receptors are are orphan in the sense
that we don't know any endogenous any
any lians that bind them yet there at
very conspicuous places for instance in
the PO of the heart that makes it pump
or in the brain and conserved across
species so they're not useless they're
being used we just don't know how and
that for one thing uh makes us not know
enough fundamental biology for another
thing creates potential side effects
that we don't understand for drugs
because they potentially activate those
uh receptors um and uh yeah also like in
designing new drugs that would
potentially want to to activate those
receptors would be important to find
which lens activate
them and of course this has been done uh
has been attempted with protein
structure looking at the molecules and
trying to see how they fit together but
our idea is to use to use spatial uh uh
genomic data sets forance what I showed
there and since we now know at each spot
in this uh section in this image what
genes are expressed at its spot uh we we
we developed a a hypothesis test and we
see that lians and receptors tend to be
coexpressed so so the liant is
expressed where there is a receptor to
hear it so nature in sense is not
wasteful in communicating it doesn't
Express a liant in a location where it
would be useless because there wouldn't
be any receptor to hear it kind of like
a tree falling in a forest when there's
nobody to hear it that doesn't happen uh
yeah they they are co uh Co localized in
nearby neighbors so right now we're
developing a generating model for for
trying to find Gene programs
shared shared between uh between
cells um yeah so so and and and in doing
so they'll be able to capture those Li
and receptor pairs so gin programs
Define the identity of a cell
uh like I was saying there's a an eye
program that makes those eyes in my eye
eye
cells uh but there's also those shared
Gene program that capture those uh
interactions between cells and that's
what uh we're doing right
now and yeah and uh that's go another
point and now we're tie uh with
nature uh and yeah so in summary uh this
went by faster than I thought I don't
know why but um yeah in in summary like
empty Dr mum um we develop this package
for powerful and accurate cell calling
uh this DP for Cal modeling coar effects
on genomic information and cell
communication for energy for
deorphanizing receptors and yeah I would
like to thank the labs I mean and with
such a great team of course I'm sure we
score another point and put uh shim
ahead uh so yeah thank you so much um
[Applause]
thanks D this very very interesting um
so I'm going to take the prerogative and
ask the first question so I um one is a
comment and then a question I mean there
are fundamental laws in nature we just
don't know all of them right right I
mean it's not it's an incomplete set so
okay um and then I just wanted to
clarify right so the thinking on the
information Paradox has evolved quite a
lot so I think um Hawking himself kind
of changed his mind as you know towards
the end right so he had a very nice
analogy which I repeat quite often but I
think uh it's instructive is that
suppose you have the encyclopedia
branica and you look up New Haven and
you know 100,000 people population
whatever then you put that encyclopedia
in a box so it's printed we read it you
know we read the information then you
put that in a close box you burn it down
so then but all the ashes from the
burning of this are contained within
that box so nothing has left the system
so what's really maybe the way to think
about the information Paradox is that we
just no longer know how the information
is stored in that Ash and we do not know
how to extract information from that Ash
so the fact that the inter information
may be there but just coded in a way
that we do not have access yet might be
an in interesting way to think about it
because as you know in the context of
black holes you know where that Paradox
was brought up now we believe that there
are potential resolutions to the Paradox
right the most promising is this island
conjuncture that prompted yeah those BB
University that were also in I'm should
probably let you finish no we should no
no but that was just a note I mean we
can discuss that um off offline but I
was curious in one of the um vignettes
that you presented of uh experimental
work and simulation work so what are the
attributes that are used to define cell
versus non-
Cell um what
yeah so these are the simulations in
single cell yeah here single cell
biology uh so so the attributes
so so what do you mean by attributes
like oh how do you what is what
differentiates a cell from a non cell
right you mentioned that so so yeah so
it's this idea that like yeah a cell
should not be damaged so it's be should
be very well preserved uh and yeah
trying to see whether you captured a
well preserved cell or you captured just
so the non cell is just a failure of
yeah faure yeah so we're trying to
capture it like try to fish it okay and
we just captured some solution with RNA
in it okay okay okay thanks yeah so it's
like mechanistic what makes it yeah
whether it's intact or not right the
information is intact okay great so that
was just a point of clarification um
questions y a question about your
discussion of siloing at
different this is actually drawing on an
example from Eric Lindberg who spoke in
the
project I'm curious whether you see this
as as consistent with the kind of of
support of news were making and he was
looking at a material science project
that was working on semi semiconductor
materials and it get segregated into
different scales so where you have
fractures in the bonds you use quantum
mechanical models and a slightly larger
scale you use classical molecular
Dynamics and then different models at
still larger scales but they can't be
siloed because there are in fact effects
that cross that cross scales that have
to be taken into account and what they
then do is they develop handshaking
models that are more localized
and you know and connecting two incom
theoretically incommensurable models but
and on for local interactions and I'm
wondering if you're seeing that as you
know advancing the point you're making
about the way siloing helps or as a
problem for what you wanted to say yeah
I guess like yeah if the length scales
are not immensely different so here
we're talking
about like yeah string scale with
respect to bacterium is is is a gigantic
uh difference of length scales indeed uh
it's not a clear cut off it's not like
if it's 10 times big in length scale uh
it's going to be zero and if it's like
nine times it's going to be uh
completely different uh but but yeah the
normalization group does explain when
you have yeah yeah this support why we
get renormalizable theories at low scale
of course effective field theories are
also immensely successful at uh yeah
describing things and they can be
predicted
um yeah no I just um wanted to add to
Joe Rouse's point that even in
phenomenology with other physical system
like if you look at Cosmic scales and
stuff the scales are actually connected
but the challenge is bridging those
scales say computationally or
observationally and putting together a
picture that includes the cross talk
between scales right so so far it's been
kind of modeling limitations that have
really prevented us to uh so they seem
siloed only because we don't have the
description to appropriately connect
cause and effect across scales because I
mean it's a you know it's a so so
gravity is a bit different uh after all
like the field theories we have for
Gravity are not uh normalizable
renormalizable um except String Theory
um um string theory is right yeah Str
the is more than realizable it's finite
um anyways um soorry so I'm sorry I
forgot uh what you asked coupling of
scales right so yeah but ultimately for
for all those simulations and that
bridging bridging of length scales
you're talking about ultimately you
don't need quantum gravity to do that
right so at the very least there is a
decoupling
between so so there are different LS in
a meta sense so so like even we think of
like Earth and like the solar system as
being on different length scales but
like our planet is like has only like L
scale of thousands of kilometers and the
sign is on millions of kilm just three
scales of uh magnitude uh whereas with a
plank scale it's it's a lot more
um yeah that's what I was trying to say
that the yeah the normalization erases
those effects
about non uh yeah relevant
operators any other
questions a short comment for you know
in different of my MMA Theory because
not not not but the thing is is uh first
it wasn't medieval it ended it didn't
end in medieval times because John
Hopkins was built on the assumptions of
MMA Theory but the link between the
theories is that for me is that miasma
theory was pointing to smells that you
know go from sick people you know but
the smells were um U made by bacteria so
nobody ask you know what this smell
coming from if they would ask that they
could end up looking at bacteria which
we discovered 200 years before they were
linked to disease sure it's a much more
complex story much a good point that you
know the questions that we ask all
always sort of
shape the connections between cause and
effect that we can make right so if we
don't ask the right questions we never
quite come to the
causes
Tim um yeah so I I know most this was
about biology and cells I got stuck at
the first at the first um slide so I
just I'm trying to understand how you're
thinking about you said oh I've got
these four forces and these these
preserve information and gravity doesn't
Newtonian gravity does gr does
preserving information is just code for
being by deterministic so this the
standard theories you have of gravity
certainly preserve information so I
don't understand why you're picking
gravity out and saying it has a problem
in fact standard quantum mechanics is
really a collapse Theory and collapse
kills information so I would actually
put the way you read it in the textbook
the first three don't preserve
information and the last one does so I
just don't even understand how you're
thinking about any of this I think
you're referring to black holes in
particular right I was referring to
black holes actually in the general
relativity there's no hair theorem for
black holes that has been taken as as
like like to get to the other point so
were more interesting that you brought
up um so so actually like the reason why
we say that those three uh qfts preser
information is also the point you were
bringing out the other day that they're
unitary so they explicitly preser
information in that sense there is there
are quantum mechanical so the moment you
do an
observation yeah you have jumping of
wave functions you could in interpreted
in a different way the standard way
would be based on uh in physics would be
based on whether they unitary or not uh
and about quantum gravity uh not just
gravity now there's this information
Paradox uh yeah by Hing and in in his
calculation he was seeing that indeed
there are no correlations the radiation
is which brings us back to your first
comment that like yeah the he wasn't
seeing any correlations the radiation
emitted from the black hole was uh
thermal right and he was having a lot of
ideas of how to try to fix those things
the baby Universe idea was actually also
his but somehow the society moved away
from that and then he himself started
thinking about uh whether information is
stored at Infinity uh those papers he
published with Stringer um a little
before he died um yeah so come back to
let me just I don't want to get to just
make a comment cuz people say this stuff
all the time and I don't think it's
correct the no hair theorem don't show
what you just claim they show because
they they show that asymptotically if
you have an actual star that collapses
there will be traces of that even even
at the boundary in the geometry in the
same way as your ashes after you've
burned your manuscript there are traces
there right the no herum doesn't say
there's that that that different initial
States go to the same final State even
exterior but but that they ASM toote to
it so it's not really relevant to this
question of information I mean I I just
think there's a lot of confusion in this
so so I think you're you're getting at
that theory that Stromer and Hawking
published about the celestial holography
and whether information is stored at
Infinity I think that's what I'm getting
by your use of ASM totically um yeah
yeah no I think
yeah yakum you had a question yeah but
it might be I don't know if I want to
ask this question well maybe it's too
early but um the question would be quick
okay about the the the fact that you
want to generalize and that you think
that the Universe has Axiom so why would
you believe that in the first place that
the universe is has axioms and is axiz
but maybe that's something for a coffee
break I'm not sure yeah maybe people
start throwing stones at me now I don't
know yeah exactly maybe cocktails even I
agree with Brandon right it's coffee is
not going to do it for that one don't R
my
Cofe I was using the term has a Theory
of Everything uh that explains all the
fundamental interactions of particles
that's how it's using
it yeah um I guess since we see theories
that do generalize uh there's a belief
that there is something that something
common it's not we're not in the North
lunch uh Zone there is a law that we
need to find out not all laws are are
for game otherwise we would be in
trouble um
yeah great thanks very much pis thank
you very much for very interesting
presentation